hey youtubers is Charlie thank you
everyone that submitted questions for
this week's Q&A I know there are a lot
of questions about where they're taking
things given the changes they've already
made so I tried to address as many you
know non-crazy spoilery questions as
possible double high fives to everyone
that submitted fansubs - some of you had
some questions about how to do that so
I'll explain at the end of this video
but just careful for spoilers if you
haven't seen the episode yet so here we
go first question zou asks am I the only
one that doesn't trust Daario I don't
like his relationship with Daenerys yeah
it looks like you're not a big fan of ed
skrein either I think that the new
Daario is a way better actor to just
just in general the thing about him that
made me really suspicious was how quick
he was to try and get Daenerys to reopen
the fighting pits
she thinks it's barbaric in subhuman
it'll take a few more episodes to get
some more evidence but I will start
freaking a little bit if he starts
siding with his door his door I think is
the one with the agenda but remember
Daario is a mercenary he can be bought
we do see him trying to defend Daenerys
in the trailer here in daznak spit so
I'm not expecting any like dramatic left
turns from the book version of Daario I
think it's most likely they'll just cut
out some of his plot just because he's
not gonna be on screen quite as much but
yeah just keep your eyes peeled on
Daario and if you're brave enough you
can keep him peeled on his butt too
because he's probably gonna spend most
of the season naked next question Dan
dino asks which episode is it that will
outrun the book so you're asking like
when will the show past the books I
think it's gonna be different for each
character
I think Sansa will be in winds of winter
territory this year so she's almost
already past her book story or even is
it the first episode bran has already
caught up with his winds of winter store
line which is why they chose to omit him
if Stannis marches for Winterfell before
the end of the season he'll have caught
up with his winter winter storyline - so
that could happen in the middle of the
season it could happen at the end
depending on how you look at the way
they're changing the younger if Tyrion
Varys storyline you could say that he's
already passed his book story - but
there is a lot of what he's doing right
now in book five and Dance with Dragons
so we'll see next question
bill tang asks do you think we'll see
mello Sandra's illusion magic on the TV
show so you're talking about glamour
magic
I certainly hope we do I mean we've seen
almost every other kind of magic for
people that haven't read the books Jack
and Huck are changing faces the faceless
men changing faces isn't
same thing as glamouring from a visual
perspective it is typically glamouring
involves the glamoured person using some
sort of charm like a jewel so i'm
alessandra could glamour someone but
she'd have to give them like one of her
jewels this kind of gets into Mance
Rayder stuff and after the episode the
creators almost unofficially confirmed
that he is dead dead for good so if they
do end up clamoring anyone on the show
it's gonna be part of a storyline that's
different from the books next question
Ramin asks how could Dany ever trust
Varys when he was the one giving the
small counsel in King's Landing
information about her I think I think
his meeting with her would involve an
intermediary like he would be introduced
to her through the group that is part of
the Targaryen restoration I don't think
he would just walk up to the base of the
pyramid and say hello my name is Faris I
used to sit on the small Council please
make me one of your advisers so what I'm
hoping is is we meet some of these other
people that Varys has been plotting and
scheming with that could be the golden
company they could tie the Dornish
master plan to the Varys Daenerys
storyline
it could be Duran Martell he could be
sitting at the top of that Targaryen
restoration I don't think he's a giant
fan of the Targaryens I think he just
hates the Lannisters next question Liam
asks which characters do you think that
they'll have delve into a winds of
winter stuff for I know Sansa will but
do you think there's gonna be any major
spoilers from the book in this season
for other characters well I don't know I
don't know about big spoilers because
the show is changing so much stuff it
depends on what you consider a spoiler
I'm assuming most the people asking
about winds of winter type stuff are
book readers who are worried that the
show is gonna spoil the books I would
say at best what the show is going to do
is just confirm a few fan theories and
the rest of the stuff will just be
dramatic departures so it won't even be
close to what happens in the books it's
like if the book travels in a straight
line think of the show is like you know
following the line for a little bit then
going all the way around and then coming
back to like the point where the show
ends up at that's actually gonna be a
lot of fun to season like trying to
figure out if the show confirms or does
not confirm or like stops on any big fan
theories but just remember the show is
gonna be vastly different from the books
in all but like the biggest storylines
next question Sirico asks since Brienne
storyline is connected to Lady
Stoneheart do you think that they'll
introduce us to her this season I'm not
expecting to
see Lady Stoneheart I do think that
we'll see some Easter eggs for her like
you know just do some visual reminders I
know Michelle Fairley's name appeared on
the IMDB page for the finale but unless
we get some more confirmation or see
some more evidence I'm gonna assume that
a fan to that and that it was bogus
next question true loner asks I have a
question about Daenerys dragons do you
think they were actually trying to harm
her or would they ever harm or kill her
if they could no I think they were just
really pissed off Daenerys dragons are
still bonded toward Rogan vissarion
regal all bonded to her that hasn't
changed but if you cage any kind of
animal it's gonna get pissed if you
don't let it out we have to assume the
dragons are being fed we don't know how
much and we don't know what they're
being fed so they're also probably upset
about that too it's like if you've ever
owned a large dog they're really sweet
but sometimes they get cranky so that's
what I think is going on with her
dragons and if you believe that
Targaryen can't be burped by fire then
she was never in any danger although to
be fair they could probably chew a
Targaryen in half one of the nurses
other big problems in addition to like
her people problem is that she doesn't
know a lot about dragon lore that's what
I think tyrion and varys can help out
just because they read a lot of books
and that's where most of the
contemporary knowledge of dragons comes
from is from old books that people wrote
a long time ago next question angel asks
what do you think about the character
Ollie the little boy from Castle black
how do you think he'll be developed okay
so this is actually a good question I
saw a lot of people talking about this
Ollie was the one that killed Ygritte I
think that Ollie will be involved with
Jon Snow's big WTF moment this season I
don't want to give away any huge
spoilers but I think that he's going to
be critical to that moment I think it'll
be a big twist on that season for a
moment like it'll be a big callback to
that but please use spoiler tags if
you're gonna comment on that just
because it is pretty spoilery next
question bent's asks why did Farris say
that Robert was a disaster I thought
that through time he was a mighty
warrior and honorable but why disaster
so you're talking about as a king I
think it was just his overspending
remember it been almost 16 years that
he'd been king and he'd been having
tournaments all that time spending the
Crown's money spending them into a pile
of debt with the help of Littlefinger so
he might not have been a terrible king
but he definitely hated ruling that the
administrative part of ruling had
someone you know with the mindset of
Tywin bin King they might have been
more mindful of what all the little
birds of King's Landing we're doing
around them like little fingers plan to
destabilize the crown with crushing debt
next question Karen asks how did the
first four episodes get leaked that's a
good question so what happens is is HBO
will give screeners to critics to people
that translate there's just like a whole
giant list of people to get episodes
ahead of time so if someone in that sea
of people took the screeners then
uploaded them to the Internet
next question John asks does Melisandre
see something special in Jon Snow she's
been eyeing him up ever since they set
foot on Castle black yeah I definitely
think that she sees royal blood in him
remember what she can do with royal
blood there is power in royal blood so
she probably wants to use him to do
something really powerful most of you
guys probably know that I'm a big fan of
the R + L equals J theory of Jon Snow as
in like his parents are a guard
Targaryen and Lyanna stark that would
give him like the most royal blood
possible I don't know that you could
quantify how royal different people's
blood could be different nobles blood
but I think that his blood is more
powerful than Stannis's which is why
she's so interested in him thank you so
much everyone for so many questions
these are always a ton of fun to do this
is gonna be really fun season I know
there'll be like a lot of questions
based on big changes they make but
there's just more stuff for us to talk
about congratulations to the winners of
the book giveaway so super lisetta and
vermilion Lotus just DME on the back end
of my channel since I have two books
it's just you know the first person to
DM e gets to pick which book they get
it's a feast for crows and it's answer
dragons both signed by george RR martin
the next round of the giveaway will
start whenever i post my episode 2 video
that'll be a subscription for HBO now
that'll be like what the weekly giveaway
is for those that are asking about the
fansub stuff if you look at the CC menu
at the bottom of the player you go in
through that it just says add subtitle
that's the menu where you do it thank
you so much again everyone that's been
submitting fansubs it's a huge help to
me and thank you for almost 30,000
followers on Twitter and 50,000 on
Facebook if you do want to follow me
there there are links for that in the
description sometimes I'll live tweet
shows if I'm not working on other videos
my next bonus video is probably gonna be
about the house of black and white so
I'll post that before my episode to
review posts on Sunday and just in case
you guys haven't seen it yet you can
click here for my episode 1 video
and you can click here to learn all
about the sons of the harpy thank you so
much watching everybody let's high five
I'll see you guys tomorrow